hey
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen zieht vorstellung heute wie
das heißt wie immer also heute mal ohne
scan weil meine komplette kamera ist
noch total ko von dem video was wir
gerade schon gesehen habe so dass real
live video was amazon und yael des ead
der mir 1 gesendet wurde kommt für eine
liste games dankeschön für diesen zieht
und zwar ist der sieht so heftig haben
ihren heftigen sieht gesehen habe habe
ich es ist nur von der landschaft von
außen nicht so toll aber von innen
aussieht ist 21 18 14 mal die 5 ich will
mich wieder wie so ein telefon 44 48 25
676 49 klicken einfach mal auf welt
erstellen und wir müssen jetzt zu
bestimmten koordinaten hinfliegen die
hat mir die koordinaten x100 7 und 10
584 genannt ich habe allerdings bessere
koordinaten gefunden wir müssen wirklich
erst mal hierhin fliegen und zwar bei
der iks koordinator 432 da überhaupt in
erics 100 132 habe ich herausgefunden
ist eigentlich ganz gute koordinate und
z600 30 ca und dann müssen wir uns da
einfach runter bauen und dann werdet ihr
schon sehen was da kommen und zwar habe
ich so was wirklich man nicht gesehen
dass es sowas dann heftig und ihr kennt
ja alle ich fange man schon mal wissen
an die kennt ihr alle schluchten
die treten unter der erde auf witzige
weise halt in minecraft oben gucken dann
da so raue
und da sind einfach nur fünf schluchten
in einander wirklich 5 ist sehr schnell
wenn man zwei schluchten oder drei das
ist ja auch schon normal hatte mit uns
darunter bauen
ich sag mal wir haben uns hier und da
sind willig fünf schluchten ineinander
und es sieht so aus als wäre das
wirklich und sperren das ist sowas von
heftig dass er mir direkt drin da ist
eine schlucht wartet dagegen schlucht
land da geht eine schlucht lang da geht
nichts schlucht lang und da geht eine
schlucht lang und da auch das 1 1 2 3 4
5 6 schluchten sogar das angeht da geht
eine durch ok 5 aber das ist so krank
das sieht aus wie ein stern das ist so
heftig ich habe noch nie so eine geile
landschaft gesehen irgendwo unter der
erde das ist so hell wie das sieht aus
als wäre da habe ich nicht in helleren
shader für und da war ja genau hier ist
ein bisschen heller rückgrat alles ein
bisschen weil ich garantieren sachen
drüber trage also die ganzen videos
kämen und zwar seht ihr hier schon hier
sind wirklich fast schlucht da es nicht
schlucht hier ist eine schlucht kg noch
so ein kleines kurzschluss drei nase
schlug du hast eine schlucht und da ist
ein stoff also das ist so heftig das
sieht so krasses da kann man echt
einfach nur screenshots machen und bor
das ist so geil also probiert den sieht
auf jeden fall aus es ist so heftig und
fliegt einfach hier zu diesen
koordinaten war da sind
es ist einfach sooo geil ich finde
dieses lied so heftig dank dann ist das
gut games der hat genau richtig gemacht
hat mir nicht nur zieht gesendet in die
kommentare geschehen sondern zieht in
die kommentare geschrieben mit den
koordinaten und was man dort findet
und darauf bin ich auch aufmerksam
geworden 23 leute gelegt also den mist
das youth games macht einfach genauso
wie er und erzählt dass man hier ganz
gut sein kommentar eingeblendet und dann
würde ich sagen wenn es euch gefallen
hat dürfte einen daumen hoch geben und
dann kommt eventuell die nächsten tag
nochmal eine sieht vorstellung wenn
immer wieder weiterhin fleißig sieht
schreibt die st agatha oben ist auch
noch ein
bums dich weg hier die heiße nummer hier
diese höhlen dungeon kein plan dingsbums
als wir sind auf jeden fall beim
nächsten mal wieder wenn ihr mir wieder
fleißig kommentare schreibt und jordan